finally I got to talk to my buddy the
one I started with he said by the way I
smoked crack for the first time last
night I was like you smoked crack he's
like yeah we that's basically what they
were doing there all night because that
that prostitute kept going to your bed
and blowing cracks smoke into your mouth
while you were
snoring because she thought you were
oding and she was going to make sure you
stayed awake and didn't die you had a
prostitute blow and crack in your mouth
while you were asleep because she
thought you were
dead why does she think that's going to
save anybody you know the upper
against the
downer Street logic I don't know hooker
would a hard to go
bro the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
[Music]
today